great detention you're done too well the
enemies are dropping like flies
[Music]
so for the past month or so there's been
a bunch of Western streamers playing on
the Korean League of Legends server it's
widely regarded as the hardest server to
climb on packed with some of the best
players in the world all playing on
insanely low latency getting Challenger
rank here is pretty much the Pinnacle of
non-professional League of Legends
things have been going pretty smoothly
for the streamers until Monday this week
when almost all of them got
simultaneously banned and it seems like
all of this was because of one streamer
TF blade now he is one of the most
polarizing n a streamers out there his
fans love his aggressive High ELO Jacks
and irelia gameplay while his critics
point to his incessant in-game toxicity
and he's carried that behavior right
over to the Korean server recently
this degenerate team this degenerative
save action here before me this
degenerate dark
piece of team Western streamers on
the server like spare shot and LS have
been the target of his flame too the
generous
moronic chaplain Pantheon too with the
early like this
and this dark can only play this
bring the champion bro come on
and then he says um LS as if that's
supposed to mean something
reject if anything that undermines your
value people can anyone support you
you're a goblin no one likes you which
is why every time your boot camp run
ends your viewership goes to nothing you
literally have no friends in the entire
scene my last week TF blades flaming and
spat with ls had drawn attention to
himself on FM Korea essentially a South
Korean Reddit on Tuesday TF blade was
hit with a two-week ban from Riot career
and he quickly came up with a solution
how is that
is my question
honestly it's fine we'll just get a new
account by Korean League account his
next account was swiftly banned as well
and here's where things get interesting
because while he was playing in his
final game on that account other Western
streamers found that their accounts had
been banned too oh nice so now I get
banned you're kidding me
oh that's
you're controlling right and here's the
thing the other streamers who were
banned were staying and playing in the
same hotel in Korea as TF blade one of
them Destiny came into Dante's room to
let him know that the Chinese Pro Player
yudang had said in the last game before
he was banned that he would make sure
all the Western streamers would be
banned hey
began to Dawn on them it seemed that
Riot career had not only banned TF blade
but they'd IP banned the entire hotel
and anyone whose account was associated
with that address
oh God whoa okay but it's because eloris
is in this hotel Newt too no what if
they're just perm about it we're getting
our asses IP band legit in total seven
streamers were permaband Dantes Yamato
detention Alois value cenerius and TF
blade so the obvious question among all
the chaos that was happening well why
were the other streamers other than TF
blade band well the working theory is
that when Riot saw TF blade using new
accounts that weren't his to try and get
around the ban they did what they
normally do in this situation they IP
banned him but of course the other
streamers accounts were also linked to
that IP so they ended up taking
collateral damage from his man now this
is only a theory as Riot career didn't
confirm to the streamers that they had
issued an IP ban only that they would
not be reinstating the accounts at that
time TF blade seemed far from remorseful
in a tweet where he claimed that he
cannot control himself from not flaming
or trolling bad players and will not
apologize lines regardless of if there
are a pro or not he said it was absurd
of Riot career to manually ban every
account associated with the same IP
address as their hotel and that he
wouldn't have gone on another account if
he'd known they punished the other
streamers he defended flaming in general
saying league is a competitive game full
of emotions and that Ryan is
inconsistent with who they punish
finally he said it was unfair to punish
his fellow streamers for him getting
banned there was some side drama going
on too with a tweet from LS in which he
seemed to suggest TF blade May face
charges for online verbal harassment and
identity theft over using an account
that's not his Dante suggested that LS
was almost willing this into existence
because of his recent drama with TF
blade where Dante's also misunderstood
what was going on there where a lot of
people seem to think that I was trying
to make something happen towards
tierplay and like I clarified multiple
times I tried to actually make it so
that something like that didn't happen
by warning TF blade because I don't
believe in canceling someone over not
doing like absolutely horrible things or
something like that in the day since the
streamers have tried with varying
success to get their accounts back Dante
has had a second account permaband and
has now decided to play on Japan's
server instead aiming to reach masters
with no losses but others like eloists
have got their accounts back with the
help of others with ls seemingly
suggesting T1 CEO Joe Marsh had
something to do with it so what can we
learn from all of this well some people
have suggested that the streamers could
have avoided all of this by going
through the proper channels and
obtaining official Riot accounts from
riotcareer now to make a normal Korean
account you need to link it to an
official South Korean government ID now
most western streamers don't have that
of course so they tend to use accounts
owned by others and so technically
shouldn't be playing on the Korean
server at all now right career tends to
overlook this though as most Western
streamers are left alone when they visit
to play if they don't cause too much
trouble the argument here though is this
all could have been avoided if the
streamers went through the proper
channels because most likely their Riot
accounts would not have been banned in
this situation Dantes pushed back on
this on Twitter though claiming that
streamers official Riot accounts have
also been banned and that this is
clearly just a case of targeted Banning
essentially it looks like Riot career
usually overlooks foreign streamers
playing on non-legit accounts if they
don't cause too much of a stir but TS
Behavior put a spotlight on the
streamers and kind of forced Riot's hand
the whole event has stirred up
discussions around toxicity in League
how Riot handles it and this annual
pilgrimage that Western streamers take
to the Korean server which seems to be
growing increasingly weary of their
presence when this kind of thing happens
right now the streamers are still in
career so there may be more to this
story yet and I'll let you know if more
unfolds
the way TF Blade's been talking and
behaving on stream you know it's no
different to how he would be in North
America or Europe and yet you see how
quickly Riot career just dropped the
bomb just level the whole thing